CHRISTINA: Welcome everybody
to today's Authors at Google
event.
We are delighted to have
Louisa Lim join us today.
And Louisa Lim is an NPR
correspondent and a former BBC
correspondent from Beijing.
Louisa's written
an amazing book.
I finished it over
the past few days,
and I strongly, strongly
recommend reading it,
as I'm sure you'll want to do
after you've heard her talk.
And it's called "The
People's Republic of Amnesia,
Tiananmen Revisited."
We're delighted to
have her here today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LOUISA LIM: Thank you
so much Christina,
and thank you, Kirstie,
for organizing this talk.
I'm so happy to
be here at Google.
I've heard tell of the
fabled Google headquarters.
So it's a great
privilege to be here.
And I'm going to
talk about my book,
"The People's
Republic of Amnesia."
It's really about the
legacy of Tiananmen
and the events of 1989, how
those events changed China,
and then how China went on
to change those events as it
rewrote its own history.
It's about amnesia, which one
very famous Chinese author, Yan
Liangke, called a state
sponsored sport in China.
And my book is
about the people who
refused to take part in
that state-sponsored sport
and what happened to them.
And the story of how
I wrote my book really
started with this woman.
She is a mother.
Her name is Tan Deying.
And I met her as I was
working on a completely
different assignment for NPR.
I was a radio correspondence
for NRP in China,
and I was in Chengdu more than
1,000 miles away from Beijing
when I met this woman.
And she told me how she, all
these years for two decades,
she'd been searching
to find out what
had happened to her son who
died in 1989 in Chengdu.
And I was pretty
surprised, because I
didn't know that anything
had happened in Chengdu.
And so I started
asking her questions.
And then the more
that she told me
the more that I wanted to find
out about this untold story.
And so I started to look for
eyewitnesses for the events
that she was describing.
And then I started to look
for photographs, for video,
for diaries, newspaper reports
from Chinese newspapers
at the time, diplomatic
cables from the US records
and other countries'
diplomatic backwards.
And by the end of
this process, I'd
pieced together this story that
had never really been properly
told before of
another crackdown,
not just the killings in Beijing
that we all know about but,
killings that happened 1,000
miles away on the other side
of the country.
And it was a story
that I actually
did not know that
I was going to tell
until I started to talk to her.
But it really made me wonder.
The central question that
I was addressing was,
how is it that something
that happened within living
memory can be forgotten?
Because, after all, this
was only 25 years ago.
And there were so
many people in Chengdu
and elsewhere who
saw those events.
So how can that be forgotten?
And the first thing
that I realized
was that memory
really is surprisingly
dependent on geography.
So when we in the West think
about Tiananmen Square,
we often think
about this picture.
Raise your hands if
you've seen this before.
OK.
Raise your hand if you haven't
seen this picture before?
So 100% and people in this
room know this picture,
that moment when Tank Man,
as he's come to be known as,
stood in front of
a line of tanks
on the boulevard, the Avenue
of Everlasting Peace, that
leads to Tiananmen Square.
I think perhaps
fewer people have
seen the raw footage
of that moment, which
is also incredibly powerful.
In fact, there was a British
playwright, Lucy Kirkwood, who
wrote a play about this moment.
The play's called "Chimerica."
And she wrote, "this is
a picture of the moment
that China exchanged democracy
for an economic miracle,
for the opportunity to work,
live, spend, progress."
So that static
shot is that moment
the we associate in the
West with June the 4th,
and with the events that
happened in Tiananmen Square.
But actually
there's an awful lot
that is also forgotten about
that moment, even in the West.
In fact, this didn't even
happen on June the 4th.
It happened on June the 5th,
the day after the killings
in Tiananmen Square.
And the fact that he
climbed up onto the tank
and he exchanged words with
the soldier inside the tank
is also forgotten.
And we don't know what he said,
but the reports at the time
say that he said.
"leave my people alone."
We also do not know
who this man is.
We do not know what happened
to him after this moment.
At the very end of
this footage, you
can see three people on bicycles
coming to whisk him away.
And it's not clear if they're
supporters sheltering him,
or people coming to
detain and arrest him.
But that moment, that
particular moment,
is really what we in
the West associate
with Tiananmen Square.
And I think there's a lot
about what happened in '89
which is forgotten in the West.
Because this wasn't a moment
that happened in a vacuum.
It was the culmination of
seven weeks of a student
and popular movement.
And that movement began
in the middle of April
when the Communist
Party leader Hu
Yaobang who had been there,
when he died suddenly of a heart
attack.
He had been the head
of the Communist Party,
but he had been removed
after student demonstrations
a couple of years before.
But the students liked
him a great deal.
He was seen as a
liberal, as a reformer,
and they felt a great
deal of sympathy for him.
So when he died, they all
came out on the streets
and they began mourning him.
And very, very
quickly, the mourning
turned into protests
calling for freedom,
for democracy, a free
press, an end to corruption,
and other demands like this.
The protests spread
around the country,
and they continued to build.
And then towards the end of
April, for the first time,
the government came out
and said its position,
which was that these
protests were turmoil,
and that they should end.
For the students, they saw
this editorial as a sign
that the government would
go after them no matter
what they did.
So they continued to protest.
And by May the 4th, there
were a million people
on the streets protesting.
In the middle of
May, the students
began a six day
long hunger strike.
And as all of this was going on,
there was also a power struggle
at the highest levels
of the Communist Party.
This was the last appearance
by Zhao Ziyang, who
was the Communist Party
leader at the time,
and he was the loser
in that power struggle.
He turned up at 5 o'clock in
the morning on Tiananmen Square,
saying to the students,
"we have come too late."
And after that, he spent the
next 15 years, until his death,
under house arrest.
So that was the moment at which
the hardliners in government
took control.
And they declared
martial law the next day.
And they sent troops in to
try and clear the Square.
This was the first attempt
the troops had made,
and this is also something
that was forgotten,
that that first attempt was
not actually successful.
These troops came in, and
as they were coming in,
just crowds and crowds of people
swarmed around the lorries.
They lay down in
front of the wheels,
and they stayed there, sometimes
for three days and three
nights.
And the troops were just
effectively marooned
in a sea of people, and
they had to withdraw
and they went back
to their barracks.
And the student saw
this as a great victory.
But as we know now, it was
only a temporary victory.
And on the night of June
the 3rd to June the 4th,
the troops were sent
in again, this time
in great numbers with
the order to take
the Square at all costs.
Even now, we don't know
how many people died.
The first numbers that the
government put out said 241.
But there were estimates
that were much higher.
The Red Cross at the time
went around the hospitals
and said 2,600 people.
They had counted 2,600 bodies.
But those estimates were later
withdrawn after complaints
from the Chinese.
So there's still a lot that is
unknown in the West, even about
those events.
But this is that
image that remains.
And I think in the
West it's really become
part of our popular culture.
It's become a meme which is so
used so much that it's really
readily understood without
any kind of explanation.
So here are some
examples that I found.
There's Obama's
first trip to China.
He's seen as a squeegee guy
begging the PLA for a handout.
In the same year,
Iran had protests
where the students were
using social media to protest
against election results.
And you can see the
mullahs in the tanks
saying he's twittering.
And he's there on his
BlackBerry tweeting away.
Then two years ago, when Edward
Snowden fled to Russia, again,
this same image occurred.
And I think that it really has
entered our popular culture.
If there was any doubt about
it, here it is on the Simpsons.
And just one last example.
It's hard to
believe that anybody
could've thought that
this was a good idea,
but here is a Tank Man
advert that was shot
for the Peach Bowl in the US.
Yep.
It was really-- that was a
true, real ad for Chick Filet.
So I think this really
shows the kind of role
that that picture has played
in our popular culture.
And when I was starting to think
about the legacy of Tiananmen
in China, what I
wanted to know was
how familiar young
Chinese people
would be with this picture.
After all, nowadays there are
650 million Chinese people
online.
And although the internet
is very heavily censored,
there's a lot that gets through.
It's quite a leaky system,
and a lot of young people
know how to circumvent
the censorship.
So one of the
experiments that I did
was to take this picture,
the picture of Tank Man,
around four Beijing
universities.
And they were the
four universities
that were most instrumental
in 1989 in the protests.
And I asked students do
you recognize this image?
And if they said
yes, I would double
check with them to see if they
really did know what it was.
And I remember in this room
100% of people knew this image.
I was really surprised to
find only 15% of the students
that I talked could
identify this image.
And you may ask, well, how can
you tell if people are lying?
And that was something
that I didn't
know when I started whether
I would be able to tell.
And it was really
surprising to me
that you can
immediately tell because
of the power of the image.
Those students who knew
what that image was,
they have this
physical reaction.
They would look at
the picture, and they
would shy away from it.
Some of them gasped.
One of them said, oh my god.
And it was clear if
they knew what it was.
I mean, there was one
young man who even said,
I do not know what this image
is, but it's too controversial
and I can't talk
to you about it.
So he knew.
Whilst the 85 students I
spoke to who couldn't identify
the image, when they
looked at it, when
they looked at the Tank Man
picture, they would lean in.
And they would point to things.
And they would ask questions.
So I was asked is
it South Korea?
Is it Kosovo?
One student pointed
at the lamppost, which
is really distinctive-- they're
only in Tiananmen Square--
and said well, it really
looks like Tiananmen,
but it can't be.
So it was clear that although
the censorship is leaky,
that it is actually
working when it comes
to a large proportion
of people in China
and young people in China.
Those students who did
know what the picture was,
often they would defend the
behavior of the government.
And they would say things
like China's economic progress
in the last 30 years was only
possible because of the actions
that the government took
in Tiananmen Square.
So it was really a
retrospective justification
for the killings based on
the economic performance
at the last 25 years.
And that's really the
government's line as well.
And it's a line which
a lot of Chinese people
both believe in and agree with.
So actually 19 of
the students that I
spoke to believe that it was a
military parade, this picture.
Because they just couldn't
conceive of any other reason
why there would be tanks
running down that road.
So that was one of the
things that I discovered.
And the other thing
that I discovered
was how nervous it
made me walking around
university campuses with
this Tank Man picture.
And I was really
surprised by that.
Because at that stage I'd
been a journalist in China
for more than 10 years.
And let's be honest.
I had a license.
I had a literal license, a
journalist card in my pocket
which allowed me to go and
ask sensitive questions.
And yet, I was really nervous.
I was convinced I was
going to be detained.
I was sweating.
My hands were clammy.
And then I realized how much
I myself had internalized
the censorship that just walking
around with a photograph asking
questions was making me
really paranoid and scared.
And I also realized if I, who
had a license to be doing this,
if I was so nervous,
what was it like
for ordinary Chinese people
who I was talking to you?
So it really made me think.
And I started to wonder, well,
why don't young Chinese people
know what's happened?
Of course, the censorship
is one of the reasons.
If you search on
Google for Tiananmen,
you will get immediately
pictures of Tank Man.
You'll get the Wikipedia
article about the protests,
and a whole lot more.
If you use the Chinese
search engine Baidu,
you get pictures
of Tiananmen Gate
and tourist
information about it.
Nothing else.
If you look in
textbooks, there's
nothing about the events
of 1989, except in one.
There's a textbook that
I could find any allusion
to it was an undergraduate
history textbook.
And it was 529 pages long,
and it had four pages
on the events of 1989.
And even that very,
very short account
contained what one French
professor, Michel Bonnin,
called a monumental historical
untruth-- basically, a lie.
But if you were a
young Chinese person,
it would be difficult to
conceive of that your textbooks
actually had lies in them.
That's not something
that you would expect.
As I said, there are
ways of circumventing
this kind of censorship.
And in particularly on social
media, we see a lot of that.
So for example, June
the 4th was blocked.
So netizens started
talking about May the 35th.
Then May the 35th, these
words were blocked.
So they started talking
about April the 65th.
And then that was blocked.
And then every year,
you have this kind
of escalating censorship,
where more and more words are
blocked.
So in the last few
years, words that
have been developed on
social media in China
around the anniversary
include "today," "tomorrow,"
"nostalgia," "when spring turns
to summer," and even the word
"sensitive word" was blocked.
Then last year, they even
started blocking numbers.
So people who were
trying to send money
using mobile messaging apps,
if the amount that they were
trying to have send had a 64 or
an 89 in it, that was blocked.
So you can see the way in
which censorship impedes
not just discussion,
but commerce,
and innovation, and education,
and all kinds of other things.
So the censorship is such
that this picture, which
was a picture of young
Chinese students in 1989
with gunshot wounds being
rushed to a hospital.
This actually appeared in
2009 in a state-run newspaper
in Beijing, "The Beijing News."
And at the time, there
was a lot of discussion.
It was part of an article.
It was a profile of
the photographer,
and there was a
lot of discussion.
Maybe the newspaper's trying
to send a coded message.
What's going on?
Later on, it turned out that
in fact what had happened
was nobody who worked at
the newspaper, not the page
editor, or the photo editor,
or the section editor,
so not even the censor--
nobody actually recognize what
this picture was and realized
that it was sensitive enough
to censor.
So to me, that's actually
a sign of both the success
and the failure of
Chinese censorship.
It's been so successful that
the institutional memory of June
the 4th is beginning to fade.
And people no longer realize
that it needs to be censored.
It's not just the Chinese
press that has difficulty
reporting on these things.
I mean, they're
basically banned.
You almost never get
reports in the Chinese press
about June the 4th.
But the Western
press in China too
does find itself having trouble
reporting on these things.
And I'm just going to show
you one last clip which
was from the year 2009,
the 20th anniversary.
And normally, if, as a TV crew,
when the anniversary comes
around, you want to go
down to Tiananmen Square,
and you want to shoot your
piece to camera saying
it's the anniversary and
security's really tight.
Blah-blah-blah.
And you have to
apply for a permit.
And you get given this
permit, which gives you,
say, 20 minutes on the Square.
And you have handlers,
government minders watching you
always.
And it's very
tightly controlled.
But you're allowed to do that.
But in 2009, for some
reason, the government
decided to unroll
its new strategy
to deal with Western press
reporting on the anniversary.
I like to call it the Umbrella
Man of Tiananmen Square.
So this is not the behavior
of a government that
is at peace with its own past.
And actually, I
should say-- last year
on the 25th anniversary,
the government,
the authorities decided to
stop pussyfooting around.
And they basically just visited
journalists in their offices
and said, you will not
report on the anniversary.
You will not go to
Tiananmen Square.
If you do, there
will be consequences
which we are not going to
share with you at this moment.
Those reporters who did
go to Tiananmen Square
found that they were often
stopped and searched.
They were pulled
in for questioning.
They were detained temporarily.
So it's interesting that
over time the reporting
on the events that
happened 25 years ago
hasn't become any easier.
In fact, it's become a
great deal more difficult.
And in my book, I
profile a number
of people whose
lives were changed
by the events of '89, the
people, as I told you,
who refuse to forget.
Among them is this
woman who is the mother
of a 19-year-old boy who died
in 1989 taking photographs
of the troops.
And she was one of
the mothers that
started the Tiananmen Mothers,
which is a support group,
a lobbying group.
It became the first
political grassroots lobbying
group in China.
And last year on the
25th anniversary,
she was part of this
commemoration symposium, which
was held in Beijing in
someone's apartment.
15 people took part in that.
This is their
commemorative photo.
And within days of
that photo being taken,
five of those people
had been detained,
and all the rest had been
hauled in for questioning.
And some of them
ended up being charged
with creating a
public disturbance,
even though this was a meeting
in somebody's apartment
behind closed doors.
To this day, one of them,
lawyer Pu Zhiquiang, here,
is still in custody, facing
charges of incitement
to subversion.
And another person who I
profile in my book is this man.
His name is Chen Guang.
And in 1989, he was a
17-year-old soldier.
He was one of the
martial law troops that
was sent to clear the Square.
Afterwards, he quit the Army,
and he became an artist.
He went to art school.
And ever since then,
almost will the art
he's created has a link to 1989,
to the events of Tiananmen.
He cannot really show or
sell his art in China.
Last year at the anniversary,
he put on this art performance
where he was in this
deserted art studio,
and he had painted dates on
the walls, starting in 1989
and ending in 2014.
And then he took white paint,
and he whitewashed the walls.
He said history is like a blank.
It has been wiped out.
And for that act, he
was detained by police,
and spent six weeks
in police custody.
Actually.
Last year, more than 150 people
were arrested, or detained,
or placed on the house
arrest in the clampdown,
which was the worst in years.
And they included people
like a Buddhist monk
who was giving a lecture on
Buddhism in a Shangri-La Hotel.
And he was also arrested for
incitement to subversion.
There was a factory worker,
a young factory worker
who visited Tiananmen
Square and took a selfie,
making the V sign like this.
And he was also detained for
creating a public disturbance.
Because back in 1989, the
students went like this.
So to me, this idea of
history being wiped out,
I could see it happening
in front of me.
But nowhere was this more
true than in Chengdu, the city
that you can see in
the middle of the map
there, more than 1,000
miles from Beijing.
Because this was a story that
had never really been property
told before.
But in Chengdu, there was
also these huge demonstrations
in the streets in April and May.
Students from many local
universities, these workers
from the meteorological
university, some government
work units came to protest.
And protesting was so
normal that instead
of asking each other
have you eaten yet,
people used to greet
each other by saying,
have you protested yet?
The students and the
protesters also in Chengdu
occupied square right
in the middle of town.
beneath the feet of this
massive Chairman Mao statue,
and they launched their own
hunger strike and settled in.
On June the 4th in Chengdu,
the square was cleared,
but it was cleared
quite peacefully.
And that's when things
started to go differently
than they had in Beijing.
Because the square in Chengdu
was cleared peacefully.
But after it was cleared,
people in Chengdu
began to hear what had
happened in Beijing.
And they came out on the
streets again to protest,
this time against the
brutality in Beijing.
And this was taken on the
morning of June the 4th
in Chengdu.
And you can see the signs
that they're carrying
read June the 4th massacre.
7,000 dead and injured.
This one says, we are
not afraid to die.
In Chengdu, the
authorities, of course,
moved in again this time with
water cannon and tear gas.
And the people started throwing
rocks and stones, bricks,
anything, bottles--
anything they
could find at the authorities.
This was the paramilitary
armed police.
And there were
basically three days
of running battles in Chengdu.
You can see here from this
shot, which I blew up.
You can see at the front
how the authorities dealt
with protesters in Chengdu.
They didn't open fire at them.
They Instead use batons, and
they beat the protesters.
And they targeted
them around the heads.
And these were
pictures sent to me
by eyewitnesses who were
there at the time, who
were inside the hospitals taking
pictures of what they had seen.
You can see from
the preponderance
of head injuries the way the
authorities dealt with it.
These protests and the
crackdown were so big
that the government could
not cover it up in Chengdu.
They had to admit to
what had happened.
They actually put out their
own version of events.
This was a propaganda
book that was put out.
Within a month, 760,000
copies were printed.
And in this book, they
admitted that people had been
killed during that crackdown.
They said that eight people
died, two of them students.
1,800 people were injured.
They said mostly policemen.
But then as I started
to look into this more,
I was really shocked to
discover that in fact that
wasn't the worst
thing that happened
in Chengdu at the time.
After that incident,
the people of Chengdu
were so angry that
they retaliated
against the government by
burning down or vandalizing
government properties.
And that includes police
cars, fire engines,
government offices.
And this was a
government-run market, which
took up an entire city block.
And it was burnt down
as an act of protest.
I used US diplomatic cables
as one of the sources,
because the US had a Consulate
General in Chengdu at the time.
And it was actually
at the center
of what I'm about
to tell you about,
the next incident that I'm
about to tell you about,
which happened in this
hotel, the Jinjiang
Hotel, which was the smartest
hotel in Chengdu at the time.
And it still exists, and
it's quite swanky nowadays.
But the US Consulate General,
he had his office there,
and he also lived
in that building.
And at that time, a lot of
the foreigners in Chengdu
had been evacuated and were
staying in this building.
So they were witnesses
to the incidents
that I'm going to
describe to you.
So it was on the night of
June the 5th to June the 6th.
There were huge
demonstrations in the square,
and the police were
trying to clear them.
And then there was
this incident where
the shop which sold
foreign alcohol
and cigarettes on the
ground floor of this hotel
was ransacked.
And then the police came
in to restore order.
And they marched all
the protesters out
and had them kneeling in rows
in the courtyard at that hotel.
So all the foreigners
who had rooms
in the front of that
hotel were witnesses
to what happened next.
They saw dozens and
dozens of people
detained, kneeling in the
courtyard, their hands wired
behind their backs.
Two witnesses said their
hands were wired in such a way
that their arms would
need to be broken.
Then they saw-- they watched as
plainclothes policemen walked
along between the
rows of people.
And they watched as
an order was given,
and the plainclothes policemen
took these iron rods and batons
and smashed the protesters one
by one, smashed their heads in.
Two trucks pulled
in, and the bodies
were thrown into the
trucks like garbage,
like sacks of potatoes, like
slabs of meat, like carcasses.
Those are different descriptions
from four different witnesses.
And I was amazed
that most of them
did not know that anybody
else had seen the same sights
that they had seen.
One of them said I don't
remember anyone screaming.
There was no noise, just
the bodies piling up
on top of each other.
They were definitely
lifeless bodies.
I imagined if anyone
was alive, they
would not survive in that pile.
So I needed to know
what had happened
in that hotel on that day.
So I went back to
the Chinese sources
to see if there was
any mention of this.
And I was surprised to
find that there was.
There was a great deal
written about this incident.
And the Chinese sources
said 70 people--
seven zero-- were detained
in that hotel on that day.
And the Chinese newspapers even
talked about the police's use
of violence against protesters.
So the big question was
were all of those people
killed in plain view of all
the watching foreigners?
And the honest truth is,
I don't know for sure.
I can't give you an answer.
Too many years have passed.
And we just don't know for sure.
What I do know is
those eyewitnesses
believe they
witnessed an atrocity.
Many of after leaving China,
they were evacuated out
and they went to
Amnesty International.
They went to rights groups.
They went to the newspapers.
They went to their
media, and they tried
to tell what they had seen.
But what had happened in Beijing
was so much bigger and so much
more dramatic, .
And there were no
pictures to this,
so nobody listened to them.
I did find picture is in the
Chinese propaganda, which
very closely tracked
the kinds of stories
that I was being told of
people being beaten up
over the head, of people
being loaded into trucks,
of people being rounded
up, having their hands
tied together, being
thrown face down
on the floor, and
this kind of thing.
But then I went
back to Tan Deying,
the woman who I told you
about at the beginning.
And I mean, I always had her
story at the back of my mind.
Because she had been
trying for all these years
to find out what had
happened to her son.
And she discovered that he'd
been riding his bicycle home.
He'd been detained by police.
She'd been told
by someone he was
detained with that he was
beaten to death by police.
And so for 25 years, she
tried to get an answer as
to exactly what had happened.
She went to Beijing five times.
Each time, she was
caught and sent back.
She was locked in
an iron cage twice.
For two years, two
full years, she
had a police car stationed
in front of her house.
But she went on.
And after 11 years,
her persistence
had a very surprising
result. She
was given by the
local police chief
a photograph of
her son's corpse.
And you could see very clearly
from this single photograph
that he had been beaten.
His face was swollen.
His nose was swollen.
There were bruises.
It was quite clear that violence
had been used against him.
In 2006, she was given a
payment of almost $9,000.
It's the first
payment that's ever
been made in connection
with a 1989 death.
Although it was called
a hardship allowance
rather than any kind
of compensation.
And so I thought if
anybody was going
to know about what happened
back then, it would be her.
So I went to her, and
I asked her, well,
were there others like you?
Are there others
like you out there
who lost their children
in Chengdu in 1989,
and or who just don't know
what happened to them?
And she looked me in the
eye, and she said, even
if I knew I wouldn't tell you.
And that was when I
realized if this woman who
had been through
so much, who had
risked so much, if even if
she could not talk openly
about what happened in
1989, then who would?
That was also when I
realized another thing,
that forgetting is not something
that's imposed from above.
It's something that people
have being co-opted into.
They've cooperated with this.
Because it's simply not
convenient to remember what
happened in 1989.
There's no benefit at all.
In fact, there's a
very, very major cost
to any kind of active
acts of memory.
So people simply do
not want to remember.
It's easier to turn away, to
forget, to never talk about it,
to pretend nothing happened.
And I'm just going to
tell you one last story.
This is about an artist
whose name is Sheng Qi.
And he was not in
Tiananmen Square in 1989.
He had gone back
to his hometown.
But he was very sympathetic
to the students,
and when he heard
what happened in 1989
he said it was as
if he had gone mad.
This kind of madness seized him.
And as an act of protest,
he took a meat cleaver
and he hacked off his
own little finger.
And he used that in
his art for years.
This is artwork called "Myself."
And he's holding up a picture
of himself as a young boy.
But now 25 years has
passed, and he has
a young son, a 13-year-old son.
And so we were just chatting,
and I just asked him, well,
what do you tell
your child about what
happened to your finger?
And he kind of looked
a little embarrassed.
And then he said,
well, you know,
normally I tell him that
I left it on the bus.
And I suppose surely, of
course he doesn't believe that.
And he said, well, I know
he doesn't believe it,
but I'm always thinking
of some kind of story.
Because he's still a little
kid, and I want to protect him.
And that's how people feel.
They feel their children need
protecting from the truth
in order to survive
and to thrive.
And there are people
who say, well,
does it really
matter anymore what
happened in Beijing, or Chengdu,
or anywhere else in 1989?
Because China's now the
world's second largest economy.
It's pulled hundreds of millions
of people out of poverty.
Does it really make
any difference?
And my answer would be,
yes, it does matter.
It matters because
history does matter.
And history matters so much
to the Chinese government
that they're willing to
spend all this money, all
this manpower, muzzling
people like these mothers
who simply want to find out
what happened to their children.
So I would say
that the cover-up,
it's not just at the top.
After all, memory is that
most personal of spaces.
It's inside your own head.
But people have allowed
themselves to be co-opted.
They've colluded with this
idea that memory is political.
And they've allowed
themselves to be party
to state-sponsored amnesia.
I'm going to end by paraphrasing
the words of one dissidents who
said, "a massive secret has
become like a massive vacuum.
The crimes of the
state are slowly
being replaced by
the crime of silence.
And that is a crime in which
almost everyone is complicit."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTINA: We've got a
few minutes for questions.
So you probably
could get one or two
in if anyone would like
to ask the questions.
Louisa, if I can just ask
you to repeat the question
once it's asked.
LOUISA LIM: Sure.
CHRISTINA: Thank you.
LOUISA LIM: So any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Did you
experience any difficulties
or any interference
while you were
doing your research for your
investigations in the book?
LOUISA LIM: Well, I was
working as a journalist for NPR
at the time, so I went to quite
extraordinary and probably
unnecessary lengths to try
to cover up what I was doing.
I mean, I was working
as a journalist,
but I was on the side
writing this book.
So I did take a
lot of precautions.
I never talked about the book
at home or in the office.
Because I lived and worked in
a diplomatic compound which was
widely believed to be bugged.
I never emailed about it.
I never talked on the telephone.
So if I wanted to interview
someone, I would never say,
oh I'm writing a
book about this.
I would just say I'm
a foreign journalist.
Can I come and see you?
And then I got increasingly
more paranoid as time passed.
So I would write-- I
had a computer that
had never been online.
And at night, I would lock
it in a safe in my bedroom
and wonder if I was going
a little too paranoid.
So I mean, I experienced
interference, but only
the kind of interference
that journalists experience
as part of their work in China.
It can be quite tough to do
your job, but it's normal.
You get used to
it after a while.
And because I think
my press handlers,
they didn't really
know what I was doing.
I mean, after the book
came out-- I mean,
I never had any
comeback, but I do
know that the Economist Magazine
wrote a very nice review.
There was this
double page review.
And when that issue of the
Economist arrived in China,
every page that
mentioned my book
had been ripped out one by one.
So it's old-school censorship.
They noticed.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So are they
trying to forget or are they
trying to [INAUDIBLE] what were
the consequences of Tiananmen?
What has changed?
Has there been any change?
Have they had an
impact or no impact?
LOUISA LIM: Yeah.
I mean, Tiananmen is a huge
turning point for China.
It had a massive impact in
every way-- politically,
economically, socially-- because
after Tiananmen, the government
policies changed.
There was no more
political liberalization,
and there hasn't
been since then,
whilst there was this decision
to do economic reform and not
political reform.
So you know politically
it was a turning point,
but there were all kinds of
other ramifications as well.
AUDIENCE: Basically they
tightened their control
as well, didn't they?
LOUISA LIM: Yeah.
I mean, before
Tiananmen, there had been
moved towards political change.
And afterwards, there
have been no more moves
toward political change since.
So yeah, control was
tightened, but there were also
other ramifications as well.
So after Tiananmen, the
leadership, Deng Xiaoping,
decided that it had happened
because young people didn't
understand what China had
been like pre-Communists,
so he brought in this huge
program of patriotic education.
And we're seeing the
results of this even today
in this young generation of
more nationalistic Chinese.
Because at school now they are
subject to this quite intensive
program of patriotic education.
And that is also a direct
response to Tiananmen.
I mean, another
thing that changed
was the security situation.
The leadership decided that
something like Tiananmen
should never to happen again,
could never happen again.
So they really beefed up the
internal security forces.
So now China spends more
on its internal security
than it does on its army,
on its national defense.
And that is also a direct
response to Tiananmen.
Because in '89, they saw how
students around the country
mobilized, how they
all rose up together.
And they decided that
protests must be localized
and must be squashed
before protesters join up
in the same way again.
So it was a massive turning
point for China in every way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned a lot about how
the people in China
at the time are moving
toward amnesia or silence.
But what about the diaspora?
Do you find that
people who leave
China are more open to talking
about it, or learning about it,
or understanding it?
Or do they also
still have that fear
from when they were in
China about talking about it
or that kind of thing?
LOUISA LIM: It's a mix.
It's a mix.
I mean, increasingly
we're seeing
large numbers of Chinese
students studying overseas.
I mean, in the US, Chinese
students are now the biggest
overseas student body.
So we are seeing more and
more young Chinese overseas.
And I've given a lot of talks
at universities in the US.
And I've found that you do get
young Chinese that come along,
and they're really fascinated.
They've never heard
any of this before,
and it's really shocking
and also quite paralyzing.
Because I'm often asked, what
am I supposed to do about this?
What can I, as a
single individual do?
So there is that
response on the one hand.
But on the other hand, a lot
of the students that leave
are the elite.
They're the students
who've been through
this patriotic education,
who've tested well at school.
And in order to get
into university,
you take these exams.
And there's a significant
political component
which involves knowing the
right stances on history.
So these tend to be the
elite, the well educated,
those that espouse the
government position.
So you do gets students that
leave China, that go overseas.
And when they hear these other
views of Chinese history,
they become very defensive.
And they argue,
and they say this
is all a Western conspiracy.
Why should we believe you?
This is not what our
history books say.
And the US, certainly, there's
been a number of scandals
that I write about in my book
where Chinese students have
really pushed back extremely
strongly, leading to fears,
actually, about academic
freedom in the US.
So I think there's
a mixed reaction.
And it's still hard to
tell, but I think, actually,
this is one of the repercussions
of the post-Tiananmen patriotic
education that young Chinese are
quite proud of their country,
and often do not want to
hear critical views of it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And so having
uncovered the atrocities
that happened in Chengdu, do
you think it's likely that those
happened all around China?
LOUISA LIM: No.
I think there was violence
that happened in other cities,
In Xi'an and a couple
of other cities,
but it was much smaller scale.
There were deaths that
happened in other cities,
but it was much earlier on.
It was in mid-April, and I
believe it was smaller scale.
It's possible that
things happened elsewhere
that we don't know about.
But I don't believe
that it was widespread.
I certainly don't
believe that it
happened in dozens of places.
CHRISTINA: And there's
time for one more question.
AUDIENCE: A little bit
more future-looking.
Mr. Xi and all the elites
are now at this beach resort
working on the 13th [INAUDIBLE]
on such and such a date.
Economists believe
that innovation
is high on the agenda.
Do you feel at some point
that would ultimately
lead to less government?
Do you think there's an overlap
between the economic reforms
towards the politic reforms?
And do you see in the
future some sort [INAUDIBLE]
of political reforms that
haven't happened maybe
could happen?
LOUISA LIM: Sorry, I completely
forgot to repeat the questions.
He asked what I see
in China's future.
I would say that we
overseas, I think
we fail quite
badly in predicting
what will happen in China.
If you look at Xi Jinping,
the current president,
there's not a single person, no
China watchers, no academics,
no policymakers--
nobody predicted
that he would come in and take
this nationalistic hard line
and launch a massive clampdown.
In fact, everybody was
talking about, oh, maybe he's
a closet reformer.
And that turned out
to be quite wrong.
So I think often
in the West, we're
quite guilty of
wishful thinking when
it comes to looking
at China predictions.
But also I think that
we know less about China
than we think we do.
So I'm quite reluctant
to make predictions.
But I do not see
any kind of signs
of any political liberalization
coming anytime soon.
If you look at what's
happening on the ground,
it's the opposite.
This clampdown that
we saw that started,
it got bad just around the time
of the anniversary last year.
And everybody said, oh,
after Tiananmen things
will get better.
After the anniversary,
things will get better.
But they didn't get better.
They got worse.
And since then, we've seen a
raft of legislation introduced
on national security, against
terrorism, cracking down
on non-governmental
organizations.
Those would make it
very difficult for NGOs,
for civil society to develop.
Recently, there was a
very intense crackdown
on human rights lawyers,
rights defenders.
And more than 200
rights defenders
were rounded up in just a
very short period of time.
Most of them have been
released, but quite a lot
of prominent ones are
still completely missing.
So I don't see any--
any positive signs when
it comes to political reform.
On the economic front
as well, I think
we're entering this period
of extreme uncertainty
where the controls are
being lifted slightly
on the renminbi, but this
has only just happened
within the last few days.
So it's difficult to tell how
far that's going to happen,
and whether this is actually
a move towards liberalization,
and why this is happening.
I think that the next few months
will be absolutely key to it
the rest of this term.
But so far as well, if
you look at the moves that
have been taken in
the South China Sea,
the Chinese have been very
aggressively expanding
their territory building
islands, this kind of thing.
And it doesn't look as
if any kind of reform
will be taken in the way that
we in the West view as reform.
The stance that
seems to be happening
is much more kind of hard
line nationalist stance.
But you never know.
You never know.
We've been wrong in
the past about China.
AUDIENCE: Appreciate it.
CHRISTINA: Excellent.
Please join me in thanking
Louisa for her excellent talk.
[APPLAUSE]